I'm Scott Morrison from 3x1 and today
we're gonna be breaking down a few of
our celebrity friends and their favorite
denim denim really started out
originally as kind of a raw product it
was something that basically came one
way we do a lot of different things to
denim to try and give it that very
authentic look and to simulate the age
that would naturally happen if you wore
a pair of jeans for years Luca is
wearing a pretty vintage looking pair of
Levi's Levi's is obviously pretty
important for your in the world of denim
I started in 1873 the 501 is probably
the most known product it's a classic
straight leg it's got an incredible kind
of like all-over wash and wear got a
little bit of stacking on the bottom so
stacking is basically when the leg of
the Jean is is considerably longer than
you're in st. John Mayer doesn't really
need a denim introduction he's a huge
fan of biz vim as most of us know
visitin is great Japanese brand that
based a lot of what they do on kind of
this American heritage idea it's kind of
a great example I think of what he does
really really well which is kind of
taking American idea with a little bit
of a Japanese twist to it and make it
his own
[Music]
so Tyler the Creator is wearing bleached
out pair of dad jeans it's kind of like
what I would call like a global bleach
there's not a lot of hand sanding
there's not a lot of hand work to make
it look super vintage I think when it
comes to the cuff you've got a bunch of
different choices what you typically
spine is you find people do a half cuff
which is basically just kind of like
pops
Tyler's wearing what looks like a three
inch full roll cuff which means those
jeans are extremely long or he purposely
wants to you know have this is his look
there's no wrong there's no right way
it's basically all comes down to
personal style
just is wearing a stretch men's low-rise
jean the low-rise jean is something
that's designed to be worn purposely a
little bit lower but it doesn't have the
drop crotch look or effect it's got a
lot of abrasions it probably started out
with some pretty significant holes
including the holes on the knee I think
those holes in the knee then a little
exacerbate he's probably put his foot
through that at least once or twice
putting holes on jeans there's a number
of ways we can do it more recently we've
been doing a lot with laser you burning
away the indigo yarns and you're left
with the weft yarns which is the white
yarns this is Kendrick Lamar he's
wearing the most original old-school
kind of looking jeans this is a raw pair
brand-new probably something like a 501
extra-long stacked this is the Jean that
I think a lot of people really start to
think about when they thought about
expensive raw salvaged denim salvaged
denim is a denim that basically has a
self edged this self edge is typically
done with a band of color the original
use of the color was to differentiate
one denim from another denim and from
one manufacturer to another manufacturer
Pharrell's wearing the country-club jean
of this group it almost looks like it
could be a trouser or a slack of some
sort
but again this is also an all-over kind
of like bleached look he's got a very
small cuff i showing off a lot of shoes
kind of a look this is all about
Virgil's got a lot going on here what
you find here is it he's basically got a
black
so black both in the warp yarns and the
weft yarns and then he specially got a
grayed out insert and that insert is on
the inseam of his jeans the only real
way to achieve that it's probably to do
it through hand sanding or some kind of
scraping or some kind of laser
applications definitely probably one of
the more complicated genes that we're
seeing in here so Kanye is wearing a
pretty interesting pair he's wearing a
pair of jeans that look like kind of a
classic straight leg silhouette maybe
even a little bit on the slim side but
what's unique about it has a lot of tint
so we used tint typically to kind of
neutralize the look of a denim a black
denim could be made to look more grey or
more Brown as it is in this case and
indigo Jean could be tinted to look a
little bit more dirty
Justin's wearing one of my personal
favorites
a pair of three by ones we make these
form as a bespoke chain and the spoke
Jean is really a made to measure Jean
you can't really make them tight enough
for him and so we actually make them so
tight we put zippers on the back so I
can get him around his boots this is
kind of a dark denim that he's been
wearing pretty much from rinse so rinse
is when we're taking the Jean that's
normally raw and we're washing it once
or twice to kind of lock in the
shrinkage and make it a little bit
softer a little bit more wearable Wiz is
wearing a pretty interesting pair of
jeans
it's the widest Jean of any of the jeans
were seeing today it's super wide leg he
has some kind of front pocket details
that have been actually removed and then
reattached
so Wiz is wearing actually a long rise
or regular rise gene whereas wearing it
is pretty low and so it's low off the
hip there's typically low-rise jeans and
long irregular rise jeans along a
regular rise Jean is worn one of two
ways it's worn naturally buckled and
belted at the waist or it's worn a
little bit lower off the hip which gives
you more of like a drop crotch look
Cole is wearing probably the most
modern-day iteration of what I would
consider a regular game classic straight
leg with a little bit of a taper it's
got a lot of vintage looking effects put
on at the laundry typically if you're
looking at the crotch of a jean of
things you're seeing that show some kind
of abrasion or called whiskers he's also
done it cut off hem so it's a little bit
tapered down to the leg opening and he's
actually cut the hem detail off
completely you can see some of the raw
cotton yarns dangling so the cut off
trend hem that's something that's been
around in the women's market the last
three or four years and it's really made
its way into menswear now the great
thing about a pair of jeans it's the
most democratic products in the world
there's high-end luxury brands of
embraced denim there's more approachable
affordable solutions for just about
anyone in the world to embrace and
that's kind of the beauty of the jeans
business is there's a lot of different
products out there's a lot of different
ways to wear but it's all about
confidence at the end of the day
[Music]